ora però ma così non
si sono
fatti vedere
castelli oggi nuovissima escape rumbo
questa è una di quelle state rumbo
paurose infatti uscita l'escape room
della bambola parlante cattiva lo vedete
lì c'è scritto mister fanì toy shop
somiglia molto a una bambola che noi
conosciamo bene scrive di 20 anni che
somiglia noi dovremo fare la guardia al
negozio di mister fanì che è un negozio
di giocattoli però succederanno delle
cose strane e devi comodi pre di pop
corn e lasciate un bel mi piace qui
sotto perché sequenza video raggiunge i
10 mila mi piace fare al 36 promo pa 9
benvenuto alla sua prima notte al
negozio di giocattoli ma perché io non
ho capelli spariti dei capelli tutele ai
fuffa e il tuo lavoro come guardia di
sicurezza di assicurarti che nessuno
ruby nei negozi si sentì dei rumori vai
a controllare assicurati di tenere
l'elettricità spenta che non iniziamo
dove vitale comunità ma perché io sono
così alta
opa ridatemi i capelli
guardate mettiamo la torcia abbandona
sembra un mix tra l'abi lo aveva
seminato e anche a di wang i
26 di adua chi messo così strano allora
vediamo mai ce miss ani trono ricordate
dell'escape rock o mista nitro non
l'avete vinto non è tutto qui perché era
stato preso per bellissima anche paurosa
attenzione che cosa basta rumore
dobbiamo capire che cos'è che dove
proviene da dobbiamo accendere
l'elettricità potrebbe essere un ladro
sono uscite le frecce dobbiamo dare di
qua ok sbrighiamoci
però diceva di non accendere
l'elettricità risorse rassegniamo non è
che poi tutte le bambole magari prendono
vita e molto buio qui e dobbiamo
accendere la luce vieni dei temi è molto
più grosso questo magazzino dobbiamo
accenderla ok
certo abbiamo accesso all'elettricità
adesso
che cos'era sembra che arrivi dal piano
dei giocattoli l'abbiamo del negozio o
brutto presentimento di cd già arrivato
secondo me si sono tutti animati
che mister fanì è andato è scappato
cappato e sì perché avete che la scatola
ecco come ha buttato a terra le scatole
e quindi fermato non si fonda nei panni
dammi ho portato qui c'è storage urumqi
è aperta infatti ci sono le sue impronte
vedi dobbiamo sostituire le sempre inter
è andato qui sul muro nella leb cos'era
quel rumore andato qua dobbiamo provare
ad andare qui anche noi noi andassimo
qua invece ma non riesco a salire vede
andare a dobbiamo per forza o proseguire
qua oppure spostiamo queste scatole
vediamo se riusciamo a fare adoro già
questi froome paurosa gente adora le
tante paurosa questo peppe guarda qui
però non so se si può fare è spento ci
si brucia lì è di vita alta reti ten
terme ne sono accorto mi sembro giorno
piano che strano questo magazzino qui
c'è una manopola di tale non si è
sfracellato ancora spiegatemi come fosse
il bilan allora preghiamo e sono apparse
delle delle rampe ok attento a non
cadere però è la miss
poi diciamola tutta non credeva per
fortuna non è di quei giochi in cui devo
comprare robox dai sono qui ti aspetto
ma come come mai quando passavo io forse
devo fare
lasciate un mi piace per portarmi
fortuna stories family
bravo mi piace
saliamo sopra adesso dice che poi
dovremo affrontare troppi ma c'è scritto
funny games vuol dire gioco divertente
numero uno
la bambola sua prima cos'era successo
che non si inventò qualcosa in
lontananza
non lo vedo non vedo niente faccia quei
sogni visto il secondo no no mi ha preso
se vai a destra lo scoprirai guarda che
non c'è nessuno che non c'è nessun
grande perché così grande
no no
seguirò drive dove saranno buona
riuscita
perché cammina così
mamma mia è bruttissimo o noiosi nardò è
andato vicino però alla fine saranno del
match e se riuscite a trovare l'uscita
su forse si può che essi sono uscita
lasciare ecco forse
perché camminino guarda come cammina
anche
allora secondo me se provi a saltare
ogni tanto voi più veloce per
allora vai dritto e poi alla prossima a
destra
ma penso si sia adesso qui a destra
in albania
adesso mia sinistra una sentita destra
altro per
non venire più piccolo certo non
rivederli hai un ottima musica
colta da risultare salta ogni tanto
bravo
vai vai mai ci si fosse così quasi brava
la palpebra la puzzola qui s'è rifatta
non l'avevamo sentita questa porta che
nel frattempo ho perso tutti i capelli
sa
bene questa è una di quelle schifo room
che mi piacciono tanto è che vi
piacciono tanto perché sigarette febbre
aspettano a dare le dice qualcun altro
noi è visto forse ci aiuterà poche qui
c'è altra gente il gioco numero 2 qui
guarda te lo giuro me no no qui si parla
di raggiungere sempre gelato è davvero
successo
bene questo è proprio un ottimo
sfracella mento perché oltre a essere
sfracellato viene macinato
anche
concentrazione
su fatta
vediamo come si sfracella vita noi non
solo fatta stranamente non so neanche io
come aprire un gioco numero dura un'ora
giovedì il gioco un due tre stella
si va di bari vai vai bye
bye bye bye bye bye baby
mama mia posso brutto vai vai fatte
manca pochissimo
siete se abbiamo parlato durante
l'epoca che succeda ma per fortuna ci
sono altre guardie con me
brava
[Musica]
mi sono fermata anche diverse tutto
paura
fermati
ma mi hanno fatto il brutto è
bravo a supporto e aspettiamo gli altri
giocatori se lo faranno
avete forte lo facciamo il tifo per ora
no 1 le eliminato da dietro no ai puoi
farcela amico guardia
ala per prenderlo così
sbrigati
[Musica]
e andiamo che proponga share
io sono bravissimi insomma tu sei molto
bravo a sfraceli
vero che lo videro
ogni volta che dico strage non mi sono
stata celata b sfracello vediamo se
possiamo passare da sotto crinale mi ha
superato
chi era io ok
no di novara senza punta piano con calma
forse non devo passare la dove doveva
arrivare poi qualche bagliore di qua qua
si dai vieni
[Applauso]
allora adesso vai tutto avanti da questa
parte guarda vieni qua e salta da qui ok
ok è così allora devi premere il
pulsante qui sull'ascensore non lo so è
piovuto
non lo so stiamo andando su e dimmi che
non c'è la bambola soprano sembra che
sembra molto alto per le stiamo andando
ecco dopo numero 3 o no che cosa succede
in questo gioco e sembra che sia un
gioco di sopravvivenza dobbiamo evitare
i robot giganti salendo su questi
blocchi arrampicandoci sui blocchi ok
solo tipo di lecco e mafioso che in
quelle non capisco che il robot giganti
mani robot e io comincerei a accusando
tutto
ora però quando si mangia di credito e
la bambola e troppi gigante proprio
robot
sono caduto
artista sta sta distruggendo tutti tutte
le costruzioni
dobbiamo sopravvivere per ancora venti
secondi 23
no io presumo
proviamo a scappare di nuovo proviamo di
qua forse qua quindi dobbiamo andare in
un posto sicuro il mio migliore dobbiamo
salire in alto così non può prenderci ma
poi lui butterà a terra tutto noi
cerchiamo di fare
e dobbiamo sopravvivere se proprio
volete un po
perché arrivato un bacio aiuta cerca di
resistere ma su qualcos'altro tra stanno
dando tutto
andiamo andiamo da un'altra parte dai
adico nasconderci qui su questa altri si
sta arrivando non so se mi sta
inseguendo penso sia ora arriva qua a
lui mancano solo 12 secondi dopo il
programma eccolo
qui abbiamo qui io sono una pezza qua
mancano pochi secondi due furono
uscita dai corri corri verso l'uscita
io sono già uscito no ma il brano che ci
siamo riusciti a sopravvivere a roma mi
sa che non abbiamo fatto anche dentro
lungo e ora qui si deve a rotolare
io trovo dove siamo finiti non lo so
come proprio vi dice che ci sarà
un'altra prova
andiamo
e molto buio in questo magazzino è
meglio usare la torcia ok
cosa mi dice che la bambola spunterà qui
all'improvviso si no
c'è dietro allora se cute no io non lo
so dove l'ho visto ho paura della
bambola a
premi ho come l'impressione che mi sta
per prendere il tè per raggiungere
seguendo mantice merce le mille ma dove
sono le vie de seta non riesco a
trovarla così un rullo o tra via
d'uscita alla fine sia un rullo
trasportatore
dove la prima di alla fine con ricorso
arrivando in finale per fortuna se ne
gli stava prendendo e ora credo che
dobbiamo salire ha passato la vastissima
scala andiamo che cosa si aspetta non
posso farlo io
vado via senza di me salita se c'è fatti
per tutti e due
e allora io vado con questo ciao
bellissimo da questa roma chi ha grandi
che bello andare in giro dalle monete
attento perché potresti cadere nella
lava
o no non sono molto prova a guidare
aiuto
ok ripartiamo con il muletto almeno
adesso non c'e slavi così possiamo
guidare traquillità
piano è infatti rallenta qui quando ci
sono le curve ok non premere la freccia
in avanti forse meglio ce piano piano
piano è vero se poi piano è possibile ma
lei quando sono io facciamo come diamara
scontri buttiamo giù di tono no non puoi
buttarmi giù attento a non cadere ehi ma
dove bisogna andare credo di qua ci sono
delle scale ci sono delle scuole cioè
non era proprio una scala era un
piano molto piano siamo troppo bravi con
questi muletti davanti a saltare
[Applauso]
è troppo divertente per andare in giro
con muletto mai piano piano piano però
bisogna rifare tutto il sistema super
complesso il guidarlo questo modo
no no che è successo è caduto è andato
in testa coda al muletto non riuscivo
più a guidarlo
lunghissimo questo stage ma si può
andare anche a piedi secondo me no fatta
ieri è
arrivato
c'è una porta c'è un altro giorgio
numero 4 o no
c'è un tubo giallo e le porterà vediamo
sembra supermario è super mario che dico
ok cominciamo
come si fa
ad un cellophane quello che ci sei
veramente
briga di
aiuto
ma rimane
credo
mi appresto abbiamo riprovato troviamo è
difficile questa inerzia via via via via
veloce veloce non perdere tempo io non
ho
[Musica]
aiuto allora bisogna stare super assenti
e quella ho fatto sparire la valvola per
un momento
attendo per voi capiremo qualcosa guardo
solo anno delle cose
non ci credo che sono ancora sono ancora
vivo
non ci credo neanche io che sono ora
vivo aiuto ha fatto
o no dovevo fare posso farlo aiuto e
proprio più misero
3 fatta
avesse la state più difficile di tutti
ok ragazzi facciamo fare stiamo alla
gente di mammona e riprovo è difficile
che è difficilissimo perché cadi brava a
ce l'hai fatto quasi
manca poco
aiuto bravissima stai andando bene
como deve saltare con dentro brava stato
dentro quel posto era pazzo ma povero
uomo quanto resta ancora di questo
impone perché adesso per le luci erano
forse c'è la sfida finale ha deciso le
frecce dicono qua ma non c'è un
passaggio quest'opera guarda dobbiamo
salire qualora presto però credo proprio
di sì perché non dobbiamo di nuovo
affrontare troppi
attenzione questo gioco comunque
superbello chi è veramente
bellissima fatto bene dove stiamo
andando questa volta saranno finiti i
giochi di sla pi forte miss tale ente
riuscito arrivare la georgia quasi fatto
non so se piacerà tanto quello che
vedete qui ci sono tante bambole guerra
che cosa vuol dire che dobbiamo andare
di là pisa perché ci sono tutte queste
prove no non passare solo fare e l'ho
detto non passare sulle bambole bisogna
evitare le bambole era mi sa che bisogna
andare dall'altra parte sei stato lui è
stato strappi a prendere queste bambole
forse era arrabbiato che hanno fatto una
versione di bambole per venderle e lui
voleva essere l'unico
non lo so quindi bisogna passare le
primarie evitandole si
ok siamo qua è sicuro che la strada
giusta questa è l'unica strada
gioca numero 5 o un altro gioco e dice
e sembra un gioco di piattaforme che
cadono dobbiamo evitare le piattaforme
che cadono aspetta
guardo ogni tanto cadono della pietà per
me ne dobbiamo andare quelle giuste
dobbiamo capire quale sono quella che
cadono dobbiamo andare veloce 6 me non
sembra così difficile
ah sì ma vedremo quante volte sei prezzo
era vitale che più amiamo dobbiamo solo
4 10 secondi è finita è sempre facile
aiuto
no perché non c'è non a fare qua ho
detto attento se diventano rosse di con
di una scarpa a nanna
ok fino a qui tutto ok
e io ho scelto quella giusta non ci
posso credere attento preparati nel caso
che trovi anche quella
quindi ho capito dobbiamo imparare il
pattern sin qui gara sono adesione
andare o non andare troppo avanti perché
altrimenti potrebbero vedere tutte io
provo a rimanere qua qua ormai geniale
questa prova questo gioco chiediamo
dov'era
pronto
ma mica io rimango costo l'uomo che mi
manca una di queste
è caduto
davvero
fatto delle piattaforme che arrivano
aspettiamo evitare ha detto dai puoi
farcela miley all'ato dov'ero io
per molto attento ok era qui secondo
terra non mi ricordo più o meno e se i
pro tieniti pronto a saltare quando
cadono nei match spero che questa
mantenga si sa
come si fa ha detto è tipico da vitale è
riuscito a fare gioco ma poi sfracellato
ok eco vitale mirino
c'è la parata e fa votare la piattaforma
il ponte dai tanto ormai sai qual è
quello giusto era sì credo
dovrebbe essere questo vediamo dai
sia quello dove sei adesso mi è cambiato
e un prospetto ma io posso passare sono
passato ciao
uscita al trenino non ci credo se si
studia moscardo
aspettano il trenino seri e sono già
salito però solo nel valore di dietro
aiuta molti che vanno dai guidando tu o
no stop in autorità
non lo so sta andando velocissimo
proposta fuori dalla dal negozio di
giocattoli vedi
aiuto che succede sono caduto dal treno
no
corso si aspetta un altro 3
è
si è saprò senato
strachan dato tutto
ma perché si è sfracellato tutto altre
riccio a salutare prima tutte bisogna
saltare prima che cadiamo in quel buco
tieniti pronto vediamo e poi come
facciamo a vedere quando è il momento
giusto di saltare e allora vediamo da
fuori allora
sta credendo e prendetelo
ancora non lo so poi tutto può portare
adesso stiamo uscendo
sono stato sotto sotto sono dei
nonni è
che i ragazzi
riproviamo proviamo a sederci davanti
ma che paura la faccia del treno
esclusiva a ok vediamo vediamo se stando
qui davanti magari ci protegge
dai danni
provocati
distrutto tutto tranne la parte di
davanti se ancora viva intanto è
tornato nando e guai
fatto è così che bisogna fare bisogna
andare la porta davanti dai ti aspetto
se poi c'è anche il gioco finale
sarà il più difficile attentato gli dirà
perché se io sto arrivando con il treno
a vapore anzi io la stessa eco vitale
mattera
rompendo turista suggellando anche il
treno e sbrigati se il gioco come adesso
devo gioco finale dobbiamo
aiuto
cosa sta succedendo siamo riusciti ad
arrivare al ragazzino magazzino possiamo
scappare questo posto tra mente la porta
principale dobbiamo premere i due
bottoni che attivano la porta principale
ok non penso che la bambola se lo
renderà semplice non battuti per sono il
bottone forse sentite qua toma non
risponda re aspetta qui ci sono quelli
verdi mentre qua dentro
dell'aquila e quel bottone treno che
ancora non è arrivata alla base sarà
proprio qui stai attenta
bottone 1 se riusciremo a farlo o no
non ti sto arrivando dobbiamo trovare
l'altro
questo tra l'altro bottone allora io
sono contro mondo non equa eccolo equa
l'altro bottone è meglio che ci
dividiamo abbiamo visto spesso aspetta
io ho premuto l'altro bottoni tu l'hai
premuto quel no non ancora non e ancora
tesi dopo minuto quell'altro vedi se la
porta e libera
o no mi ha incastrato non la porta non è
aperta ma anche un altro bottone youtube
sarà
ho premuto no mi ha preso totale in
continuazione così forse si stanca ma
che rumori fa quando cammina non premere
l'altro per l'altro bottone e li fondo
no ma purtroppo dobbiamo attivare due
bottoni se ferrara mente quindi io devo
comunque attivarli tutte e due e anche
vitali deve motivare
si è scappato
aiuto eccolo che arriva
mamma mia
lo sento risparmiando
[Musica]
ok portati va a 36 dietro è forse la
francia un difficile lo portai avvertono
cioè stai facendo bravissima
scappa scappa scappa come detto sì sì se
si scappa sul muletto tu
addio
proprio per sempre bambola
mai fatta
brava bravissima fatto difficilissimo ma
ce l'ho fatta e ora aspettiamo vitale
vediamo se ce la farò slavi dietro che
mi segue vediamo se
si
spiaccica tale è stata troppo 6
proprietà 10 10
mentre nei commenti la state mi piace e
ora vi lascio a 4 cliccare per vedere in
altri altri video al cut su quella che
preferite visione ciao